hello campers I am Anthony also known as
deaf our tour on freako camp and github
and thank you for joining me on this
short hike about open source code I'm
going to explain open source code by
comparing it to its opposite close
source code there are a variety of
models in between the two and we can
learn more about those at a future date
open source code is published shared
public and supported by the community
closed source code is not published it
is not shared it is not public and it is
not supported by a community what makes
open source code so important to us is
the fact that it is supported by the
community
anything that is created with open
source code is done by those who use it
the community an example of open source
code would be Linux software its
opposite would be Windows or Mac OS 10
operating system Linux was created and
is available for free and it is
supported by the community all open
source code is not free some are most
are but the major difference between
open source code and all other types of
code is the fact that it's the code is
available for you to use and then
approve upon an example would be a
recipe you can find recipes online but
you can also buy the same products in
stores and not have access to the
recipes an example would be Coca Cola
you can get cold color in a variety of
flavors if you want a new flavor of Coca
Cola you must wait for the organization
who owns the recipe to make that new
flavor you can ask for it but there's no
guarantee you'll get it whereas with a
recipe you can find for your own Cola
online you can download the recipe make
changes to it make your own color your
own cherry your own vanilla your own
chocolate color and then you can share
that with the rest of the community
and that would be an open-source recipe
and open-source product again
open-source it is public published
shared and it is supported by the
community and it is approved upon by the
community all other types do not fit
that criteria thank you for joining me
on this short hike about open source
code please stay tuned for the short
quiz afterwards thank you